brand-new fallout after President Trump
commuted the three-year prison sentence
for his former associate Roger stone top
Democrats are blasting the move it's
staggering corruption but I think it's
important for people also to know that
it's a threat to our national security
this is absolutely outrageous that the
President of the United States could be
so brazen as to you know commute and
pardon his friends who are protecting
him the president through this
commutation is basically saying if you
live for me
if you cover up for me if you have my
back then I will make sure that you get
a get-out-of-jail-free card and here's
President Trump reacting today they
found nothing
initially but it went on for two years
or longer and no I did I'm getting rave
reviews for what I did for a Roger stone
and he frankly is going to go and now
appeal his case he had a jury forewoman
who hated Roger stone and who hated
probably me but she went in a false
pretense and he wasn't given a fair
trial it wasn't it's not a fair trial
wasn't given another try should have
been given another trial Jesse one of
the most surprising things about the
Democrats reaction was that they were
surprised this move was telegraphed from
the very beginning yeah I just can't get
over Trump's hair right there did
anybody notice the size of the hair with
you not wearing a tie yeah I know
everyone's changing their look and in
the pandemic I listen honestly stones no
saint he's been in the gutter for
decades but he's not a criminal either
he's an old man who likes to talk a lot
of trash and got caught up in a frame
job honest honestly like if a guy plants
a gun on you and he's a police officer
and you throw the gun in the river you
can't be charged with obstruction
it's a dirty investigation and as we
know it was a baseless investigation
there was no collusion it was a
witch-hunt
and now the media is just mad because
the witch-hunt got exposed you know
Flynn's gonna walk stones going to
walk the rooms on the March but you know
listen it's it's it's honestly it's I'm
tired of looking back at this we really
need to go forward with the Democrats
got caught trying to frame people and
you know Chelsea Manning he got commuted
by Barack Obama he conspired with
WikiLeaks Roger stone didn't conspire
with WikiLeaks and and he is now in
trouble I mean things backwards I think
Bill Clinton didn't he pardoned his
brother or his business partner but this
is the craziest thing I mean he
important the biggest tax cheat in US
history because his wife gave a million
dollar donation at the Clinton
Foundation come on
little perspective here I was going to
bring up to Greg do you remember the
Obama commutation of Oscar Lopez Rivera
you know that happened over here on
there I've he's like I think an actual
terrorist there wasn't as much outrage
aln yeah FAL and I remember that look
the last person who should be talking
about abuse of power as Adam Schiff this
is the guy who marshaled the entire
impeachment proceeding which crippled
our government with hearings and media's
hysteria while others including myself
were screaming and pointing to Wuhan
saying there's a huge thing going on
here but everybody was so the media and
the Democrats are so into impeachment
that we did not get an early start
fighting the virus and instead now we
were facing with larger issues that
we've been dealing with because we were
too busy trying to unseat a president
because we didn't like an election so
save me the the whining about Roger
stone one of the developments that
happened and why I think that we're
going to hear more about this one is
that robert muller who did the
investigation or did this you know the
special prosecutor he wrote an op-ed in
The Washington Post that said that the
jury spoke that there is a conviction
here now he has maintained that he would
not talk about it that he would just let
his report stand but now that he has
written this op-ed Lindsey Graham the
senator from South Carolina and the
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee says well then now you've just
given yourself an invitation to come and
testify and
in front of the Senate do you think
that's a good or bad for the Democrats
to bring all this up again
you mean politically Dana yes
well politically it's probably good if
you're going to have a review of all
that's happened in the past with regard
to what took place in terms of the
president's campaign all the contacts
with the rush nothing and Wikus tree
well of course something took place
there are hundreds of contacts and
that's why you know even big are the
current Attorney General okay the
current Attorney General said that
stones conviction was appropriate and
lawful and he opposed what the President
did but I just think it's important for
people who watch our show to know that
this is not some liberal media going
ballistic that today you had the
Conservative National Review described
what the President did in commuting that
sentence as indefensible you had the
conservative Wall Street Journal
editorial page drawing some of the
comparisons to Clinton stuff but saying
when you commute a friend's sentence
that's an abuse of power in their
opinion so that those are conservative
outlets speaking directly to what took
place and I think that you have to
understand even when Clinton pardoned
mark rich he did it as he was on his way
out I think this is like a thumb in the
eye to the justice system from a guy who
says he's mr. law and order when it
comes to a street criminal but not to
his friend who has clearly clearly
broken the law and is even force Robert
Muller his hand Dana to come out and say
you know this is wrong
yeah although it's an interesting
comparison case you think thumb in the
eye by the Clintons of his but what
Clinton did was mark rich was like the
thumb in the eye to the entire country
I think yeah but I think this situation
look the president is not denying that
Roger stone committed a crime which is
why he did a commutation and not a
pardon first of all but this idea now
that somehow Adam Schiff is making the
argument that Roger stone lied on behalf
of the president lie
to cover it up are we really to believe
that the Robert Moeller Special Counsel
investigation hinged on Robert are on a
Roger stone the one person who may have
had information considering hundreds of
subpoenas thousands of interviews
thousands of hunting a hundreds of
thousands of documents millions of
dollars a wide-ranging team of
prosecutors who had access to all kinds
of information we're really to believe
from Adam Schiff that Roger stone is the
one person who who made it all just go
away for the president I mean that's
laughable and this is about the
principle that if people during the
Obama administration who engaged in
corruption by the way by using the
federal government to go after a
political camp political campaign can
get away with lying like Andrew McCabe
for example as a Deputy Director of the
FBI and they don't go to jail for it
well then why should Roger stone go to
jail for it so it's a commutation not a
pardon but it is about the idea that you
know there shouldn't be a double
standard standard to your based on
politics whether you're a democrat or
republican well I understand tone it
gets exactly one of the things that he
yes sir do you think that he actually
wrote that op-ed
[Laughter]